Legend tells of many ancient weapons, many
of them imbued with great power.
Hammers that can call forth the very forces
of the heavens themselves, raining down devastating
thunder storms and electrifying bolts of lightning
to vanquish any foe.
Or, there’s the Arthurian myth of a blade
buried deep in the heart of a stone.
To any ordinary person, the sword is unmovable,
it won’t budge no matter how much force
is exerted on it, or how physically strong
the person trying to pull it is.
Only if one of purest heart, and truest virtue
should ever reach for its hilt, then the sword
will spring free, and grant the holder the
rightful rule over the land.
But there is another weapon, another sword,
bestowed with a power as old as time itself.
Some have heard tales that it was forged of
pure shadow, by a demon seeking dominion over
all creation.
Other stories will claim the blade itself
is alive, and capable of bonding itself to
a host.
While it grants its wielder the means to fell
an entire army with a swing of its blade,
the weapon also curses those who seek to covet
its destructive power, slowly destroying them
the longer they possess this unholy sword.
Such a powerful tool of devastation would
wreak chaos on this world and any other.
But this…
well, this is not that sword at all.
Actually, the ‘weapon’ in question – even
though it technically doesn’t count as one-
isn’t some magical item.
In fact, its only real power is causing all
its various owners over the years to end up
needing a serious trip to the ER.
So, this is SCP-572.
Okay, sorry, I’ll do the voice again – but
this is the last time.
Or, as the legends call it, The Katana of
Apparent Invincibility!
Now just like the ancient weapons of legend,
this katana has changed hands a number of
times over the course of human history.
One of those to wield its completely un-incredible
power was Jonathan, a young man with high
hopes of going viral online as a master swordsman.
However, while most would only ever gain that
title after years’ worth of study, practicing
complex hand-to-hand combat forms, and learning
to respect the blade itself and the craftsmanship
used in making one…
Jonathan just read a WikiHow tutorial on sword
tricks and, deciding they looked easy enough,
decided that he could just wing it.
Of course, the first step in becoming a master
swordsman – without putting in any of the
work – was to find an actual sword to use.
And luckily, the pawn shop in Jonathan’s
hometown had the very answer to his low-effort
dreams.
Hanging there behind the counter, displayed
on the top shelf with a thin layer of dust
coating it, was the Katana of Apparent Invincibility.
The store’s owner had long since forgotten
it was even there, and was happy enough to
mark the price down for the sake of getting
rid of it.
The moment he held it in his hands, Jonathan
felt unstoppable, like he could conquer his
whole town with the power of this mighty sword,
that was barely sharp enough to cut wet toilet
paper.
He knew it would only take one show of the
weapon’s very arguable might to cement him
as one of history’s greatest swordsmen.
Unfortunately, the stunt that Jonathan attempted
went about as well as you’d expect.
Naturally, an elaborate stunt involving a
blunt katana and Jonathan’s friend, Kali,
on a BMX bike was sure to be a perfectly safe
combination – any sane human being would
tell you that, right?
After setting up his phone at the skatepark
and hitting record, Jonathan called for Kali
to ride down one side of the half-pipe and
up the other, while he used his newfound sword
skills to cleave the front wheel of her bike
clean off in mid-air.
Having been promised a replacement bike paid
for by all the hits this video would get online,
Kali went down, then up… then straight back
down.
Jonathan swung the blade, only for it to get
lodged in the wheel spokes, bringing his friend,
and the solid frame of her bike crashing down
on top him in a heap of tangled limbs and
metal.
All the while, nearby skaters filmed the mess
on their phones; the ones who could hold back
their laughs anyway.
Sometime after the skatepark debacle, SCP-572
would end up in the hands of yet another would-be
swordsman, with just as… ‘impressive’
results.
Martin Zeepleburger had grown into quite a
controversial figure over the years, garnering
his own legend of sorts, although not a reputation
that any mythical warrior of old would ever
want.
You see, Martin had founded a website that
had, in its earlier days, introduced the internet
to a brand-new way of communicating and keeping
in touch with their friends and family.
And, as a result, he had accumulated a staggering
amount of cash to show for it.
But running a social media app didn’t keep
the lights on forever.
Despite his company growing into a multi-million-dollar
corporation, the market had become saturated.
More new and innovative sites run by Martin’s
competitors began appearing, each new one
more unique than his had ever been back in
the early days.
Keeping up and still making money was hard,
so Martin resorted to gathering the personal
data of the millions of users his site had
amassed over the years, and selling that information
to… well, anyone who would pay him.
Understandably, people were a little upset
to hear that all their private information
was being shared around so brazenly.
That’s when rumors of Martin’s… interesting
behavior started to be made public by some
of his former employees.
The internet had already been rife with jokes
at Martin’s expense.
His stunted manner of speaking, strange barbequing
livestreams filmed in front of what looked
like a green screen, along with many other
quirks were often the subject of ridicule.
Some even speculated that he was a collection
of various things –a robot, an alien, even
an iguana – pretending to be a human being.
Then there was his choice of office equipment;
specifically, a certain Katana of Apparent
Invincibility.
Given his considerable net worth, the programmers
working in the head offices of Martin’s
social media company knew he had somewhat
expensive tastes.
That was what made it all the more baffling
that he bought what looked to be a very poor-quality
western knock-off of the traditional Japanese
samurai weapon.
The metal it was forged from seemed to be
unpolished, unsharpened, and unbalanced.
Overall, it just seemed a bit of a mess, even
to those in the office unfamiliar with katanas
or their cultural significance in Japan.
Yet, when he described it, Martin seemed enamored
with the sword, citing how incredible the
balance was and how the obviously very blunt
weapon could more easily slice through solid
steel than one of those infomercial knives.
Of course, the more pressing and unsettling
question for most of the employees was why
the hell did their boss think it was okay
to bring a katana into the office?
When any of the staff working there built
up enough courage to approach their ‘eccentric’
sword-toting boss to ask him, Martin would
simply state that it was a measure to encourage
more productivity.
If he was unhappy with the coding work his
programmers were doing, or the content being
posted to his social media site, Martin would
start strutting around the office.
His head was always tilted back, smugly looking
down his nose at his staff – who he’d
sometimes affectionately call his ‘underlings’
or ‘drones’.
With a look of self-important superiority
and one hand constantly resting on the hilt
of his katana, his ‘productivity patrols’
managed to put everyone in the office on edge.
Less because they were threatened by the blunted
sword or Martin’s unimposing five-and-a-half-foot
stature, but more because the staff all agreed
that what he was doing was just plain weird.
One morning, Ned, one of the staff members
working at the office, was casually sitting
at his computer, working his way through rewriting
a few lines of code as he’d been asked to.
Suddenly, he felt something cold and metal
resting on his right shoulder and felt the
presence of someone leaning over him uncomfortably
close on the left.
Immediately his heart jumped in surprise and
fear, only to instantly drop back down to
a normal beat when he remembered that Martin’s
sword was barely sharper than a butter knife.
“Hey, Mr. Zeepleburger,” Ned sighed.
“Hey there, Nedry,” Martin replied.
His voice sounded like he was trying to smile,
but also didn’t know how long it was normal
to hold it.
Also, Ned’s name wasn’t short for Nedry.
“You know, you were asked to finish up this
coding an hour ago,” he continued, even
though Ned had only been told the code needed
rewriting that long ago.
“If you don’t hurry up, I might just have
to chop you into bits with my huge sword.”
Martin forced a laugh, as though he’d never
actually expressed humor before.
Eventually, the employees had grown sick of
Martin brandishing his katana around the office.
They didn’t feel threatened, so much as
they were just annoyed; it was distracting
them from actually doing their jobs.
When a group of them, led by Ned, marched
into his office to formally complain in solidarity,
Martin spun around to face them in his desk
chair, his useless sword in his hand.
“So, this is treason then,” he smiled
to himself as if he’d been waiting for this
moment, drawing the katana.
In his head, Martin was about to leap forward
over his desk, in a move ripped straight out
of a Star Wars movie.
He thought he would easily spin through the
air, hurtling towards his group of employees
with the blade ready to skewer the nearest
ones for daring to question his leadership.
Unfortunately, despite his surfing trips in
Hawaii, Martin wasn’t exactly nimble enough
to pull it off.
He barely jumped high enough off the ground
to clear the desk, knocking the whole thing
forward and tumbling over it.
Landing awkwardly, the tip of the blade barely
reached far enough to lightly graze Ned at
the front of the group.
Instead, all of Martin’s employees looked
at him pathetically laying face-down on the
office carpet.
After changing hands who knows exactly how
many times, the Katana of Apparent Invincibility
would soon find itself in the hands of another
soul just as worthy of wielding it… and
making themselves look really dumb in the
process.
For as long as he could remember, Zac had
been obsessed with superheroes.
He had spent his youth reading comic books,
idolizing characters like Batman who fought
criminals on the mean streets to deliver swift
and brutal justice.
Even as he got older, Zac never outgrew that
childhood dream he had held onto: to become
a real-life superhero.
Now, obviously, he knew that superhuman powers
were a little out of his reach.
But that never stopped Bruce Wayne; Zac could
train himself, build up his physical strength
and learn to fight.
Of course, he overlooked the part where Bruce
Wayne also had billions of dollars inherited
from his parents at his disposal, not to mention
a cave with lots of fancy high-tech gadgets,
an English butler, and had trained under some
of the most skilled hand to hand combatants
in the entire world.
Batman never learned karate during night classes
held at the local community college.
Still, there was nothing that could deter
Zac from his heroic aspirations.
He spent every free moment he had in the gym,
lifting weights, and building his biceps to
the size of burger buns.
After failing his exam twice, he achieved
the coveted blue belt in his martial arts
class, and he even ordered the parts he would
need to construct his super suit.
Sure, Zac told himself, it might have just
looked like a ski mask and some hockey pads,
but he needed freedom of movement as well
as protection.
There was only one piece left to complete
this stage of his origin story: a kickass
superhero codename.
That was when fate seemed to step in, taking
its rarest of forms: an eBay listing for a
used sword.
From the moment he saw it, Zac knew he needed
to own it.
Not all superheroes used weapons, but he figured
it would be a good deterrent.
He’d only ever draw his blade to wound,
and only when there was no other option.
As he placed his bid, Captain Katana was born.
It was his first nightly patrol; Zac had donned
his protective suit and concealed his secret
identity behind the mask.
The katana was sheathed and strapped to his
back, for now, but he was sure enough it would
soon see its share of righteous vengeance
before the night was over.
Well, more accurately, it would cause more
than its share of mishaps by the end of the
night.
But Zac… sorry, ‘Captain Katana’ didn’t
care.
He felt unstoppable, in fact, ever since the
sword had arrived in the mail, he had been
feeling like he could take on the world.
The would-be hero thought it was just the
anticipation of finally being what he’d
always wanted to be, exactly what his training
had been preparing for.
How was he to know that the sword itself was
the reason for his dangerous amount of overconfidence?
You see, while it might not be imbued with
ancient magic, the power of a god, or the
ability to suck the souls of its victims,
there is one thing remarkable about SCP-572.
Okay, well, two things; the first being just
how bad it is as a sword.
It isn’t forged from any high-quality steel,
or made by an elusive Japanese swordsmith.
Whereas a katana made with the proper amount
of skill, craftsmanship, and care is perfectly
weighted, and balanced evenly for the right
amount of speed and swiftness in combat, this
one is… well, none of the above.
And as if it wasn’t bad enough that it lacked
all the other qualities of a true katana,
SCP-572’s blade is totally blunt.
Seriously, you couldn’t even slice bread
with this thing.
And yet, in his heart, Zac felt like it was
the perfect weapon, the most powerful tool
in his vigilante war on crime.
Speaking of crimes, he thought he’d found
his first prey for his nightly hunt.
The sound of a car alarm was blaring through
the city streets, coming from somewhere nearby.
Our woefully underequipped and underprepared
hero raced a few blocks over to find the source.
From a distance, all he could see was a man
fumbling with the door of a locked car, clearly
unable to open it and trying to force his
way in.
What this so-called hero didn’t think to
do was assess the situation for any further
context, too quick to trust in his ‘instincts’.
“Stop right there, thief!” he declared,
unable to hear how muffled his voice sounded
when filtered through the material of the
ski mask.
The man froze and turned to look at the figure
approaching him, only to raise an eyebrow
in confusion.
“Um… hello?” he called back.
“Can I help you?”
“Silence villain,” the masked onlooker
shouted, just audible over the noisy car alarm.
“You’ve got two choices here: either you
walk away, leave that person’s property
alone and I’ll let you off with a warning.
Or, we do this the hard way, and you’ll
face…”
Zac paused for dramatic effect, like he had
practiced in the mirror.
“The wrath of Captain Katana!”
“Of who?”
the other man replied.
“Look man, I’m not sure what your deal
is, if this some kind of cosplay thing or
you’re just… nuts.
But this is my car, okay?
The door gets stuck, I just need to jimmy
it a little sometimes, but it sets the alarm
off.”
“Liar!”
Captain Katana yelled, reaching over his shoulder.
His gloved hand gripped the hilt of his weapon
and pulled it free of its sheath.
From across the parking lot, the driver couldn’t
tell how utterly useless the sword was at
his current distance.
All he saw was a masked, potentially unhinged,
stranger dramatically pacing towards him with
what was very clearly a weapon.
“What the hell?” he exclaimed, urgently
trying to get his car door open.
The handle gave way and the door sprung open,
allowing the man to hurriedly climb into the
diver’s seat and shut the door behind him.
Starting the engine, the lights came on and
illuminated the stranger in front of him,
who stood looking absolutely ridiculous in
his outfit; consisting of what looked like
various pieces of sportswear.
Katana in hand, the ‘superhero’ was still
striding slowly towards the car as the engine
spluttered into life.
Zac stopped, smiling under the material of
his hockey mask, as he gripped both hands
around the hilt and took a wide stance.
Flooring the accelerator, the driver was eager
to get away from this obvious lunatic, even
if he was wielding a sword that was mostly
unusable; it didn’t seem like that would
stop Captain Katana from trying to use it,
no matter how unsuccessfully.
The car came barrelling towards Zac, and he
readied himself, lifting the blade high above
his head.
He knew that he would be able to bring it
downwards in a vicious swipe at precisely
the right moment.
The second the worn-out, dull metal connected
with that of the car, it would slice the ‘stolen’
vehicle into two perfect pieces, split right
down the middle, leaving the ‘thief’ confounded
and ready to be handed over to the police.
You can already guess that’s not what happened,
can’t you?
With barely a screech of tires against the
concrete and without even enough distance
to build up much speed, the car headed straight
for Captain Katana.
He made a flailing, uncoordinated swing far
too early, causing the sword to bounce right
off the hood of the car.
The force of the impact wasn’t huge, but
it was enough to cause the katana to slip
from the wannabe hero’s hands; helped by
the fact his gloves didn’t have that much
grip on them.
The Katana of Apparent Invincibility was sent
sailing through the air, and came clattering
to the ground, rolling under another car in
the parking lot.
Although, Zac was a little preoccupied to
see where it landed.
No sooner had he lost his grip on his ‘almighty
weapon of justice’, around three and a half
thousand pounds of metal collided with Captain
Katana.
Felled on his first ever night as a superhero
by his very first villain.
Still, Zac at least learned what his Kryptonite
was, his greatest weakness, just like so many
classic superheroes had.
His just happened to be being hit by a mid-size
sedan.
Tumbling back onto the ground, the back of
Captain Katana’s head thumped heavily against
cold, hard concrete, leaving him with a concussion
and an overwhelming sense of embarrassment
as the driver parked his car and called an
ambulance.
At least he now knew he never wanted to pick
up that sword again.
You see, that’s the second remarkable thing
about SCP-572.
Anyone who picks it up instantly perceives
it as a mighty weapon, the kind you would
find in an ancient legend.
Despite the sword being crudely made, blunt,
and generally unfit for any use, the wielder
will maintain the belief that it not only
has perfect balance and cutting power, but
that the sword has also imbued them with unparalleled
strength and invincibility to damage.
It's all a delusion, of course, and whoever
holds that sword will gladly prove it to you.
They’ll try to perform incredibly risky
stunts with it, only to end up severely injuring
themselves in the process.
Don’t worry though, if you ever come across
SCP-572, it’s nothing a quick thump in the
back of the head won’t fix.
Now, if you want to hear about an actual all-powerful
sword that can obliterate anything on an atomic
level, as well as the ancient energy building
who wields it, then you should go and check
out “SCP-001 THE GATE GUARDIAN”.
And, of course, sometimes the only thing better
than one katana is two katanas and an infamous
comic book character.
But will that be enough to take on the Hard
to Destroy Reptile?
Find out in “DEADPOOL vs SCP-682”!